(soft music)
- So when I was invited to give a tutorial
or the lecture at the summer school,
I was told to talk about
the modern architectures
in deep learning,
and I realize that in
fact, surprisingly so
the network neural net architecture
hasn't really evolved that
much ever since 2017 or 2018
when we started to use
attention everywhere.
Instead, I thought, okay,
let's try to think of a case
where we can view many
different, let's say perspectives
into training deep neural networks
from a perspective of the
neural network architecture.
And then what would be the
best way to demonstrate this?
I thought was the hyperparameter tuning,
which is another way
to look at optimization
or the network architecture,
but from a one level up.
So today's lecture is going to be
about the online hyperparameter tuning,
and I want it to be as
interactive as possible.
I understand that online
setup is very difficult
for any lecture to be interactive,
but I do have a recording
of this particular lecture,
it's not going to be exactly the same,
that I can share with
all the students later
so that they can review it.
So if you have any
questions as I go about,
because I'm going to cover a
lot of background materials,
do ask and then Sarah will be able
to relay the questions for me,
and then I can answer all of them.
So when I think about optimization
or the network architecture
or whatever you want in deep learning,
I always imagine four different stages.
One is preparation because
at the end of the day,
what is the most important thing?
It's to prepare data properly
and then prepare what kinds of models
that we are going to use,
or what kinds of optimization algorithms
we are going to use properly.
And then after the preparation is done,
we actually do have a two
stages of optimization.
In the first stage, which we
often refer to as training,
we pick one particular model architecture,
network architecture,
or the one particular
hyper-parameter optimization,
or I would just refer to
all of them collectively
as a hypothesis set,
and then trying to find a solution
within this hypothesis set,
that's going to have the
minimum average training loss.
And then that's the second
stage of the training.
And then after that is done,
of course it was an optimization problem.
In the third stage
that is often referred
to as model selection,
we solve yet another optimization problem.
Where we're going to look
at multiple hypothesis sets
and there could be as many
hypotheses as you want.
And we trying to find the
one of which the solution
corresponds to the minimum validation loss
so the average validation loss.
After the model selection is done,
we are done with the optimization.
and then we enter the stage,
the last stage of reporting.
So we need to report or tell other people
who are going to use our model,
how well this model is going to work.
And then for that,
we are going to simply
compute the average test loss
and then report it
together with our model.
And today I'm going to
focus on these two stages,
the stage two and the stage three
that are all about optimization.
Now, training, most of
you already know yourself
and that you probably
have learned about it
from the three earlier
lectures of this summer school.
For training,
we almost exclusively use
stochastic gradient descent
or a variant of stochastic
gradient descent.
And in stochastic gradient descent,
we're trying to find the classifier
that is parametrized with theta
which refers to collection
of the parameters.
So in the case of the neural network,
we have a very large neural network.
And then we have all those weight values.
And then all of those weight values
are going to be referred
to collectively as theta.
And then we often need
a differentiable per
example loss function, L.
So for each of the example
in the training set,
we want to know how well this
classifier's prediction is
with respect to the ground truth, Y?
And then we want this
per-example loss function
together with a classifier
to be differentiable
with respect to the
parameters of this network.
So we don't care whether
it's differentiable
with respect to the ground
truth, label Y or the input X,
but with respect to the parameters
we want it to be jointly differentiable.
And we often need to have a
differentiable regularizer
such as a weight or what
not that's going to ensure
that our hypothesis set is
properly regularized or limited
so that we are able to avoid
overfitting to a training set
without generalizing to a new example.
And why is this stochastic
gradient descent?
Because if you have noticed,
then in fact computing this loss function
or the gradient of this loss function,
entire loss function with
respect to the parameters
is extremely expensive.
What do I mean by that?
We need to evaluate how
good this classifier is
for every single training example.
Every time we compute the
gradient of this loss function,
and this is simply not scalable
in particular, in this
era of so-called big data.
We have data sets that has
often let's say millions,
if not billions of instances.
And if you have to go through
billion different examples,
every time we make a tiny
update to the parameters,
that's not really what we want to do
nor we can afford to do so.
So instead we have to be a bit stochastic,
and then say that we will use
a very small mini batch at a time
and then compute the gradient
of this mini batch loss function.
To do so, all we need to do
is evaluate this function
or the neural network,
as many times as there are
examples in this mini batch.
And this mini batch size
can be as small as one,
to sometimes several thousand only.
And then compared to the
say, millions or billions
that we are talking about
over the size of the
training set we talked about
is pretty reasonable.
We can manage it, right?
And then when we do so, we need to think
about what kinds of
hyper-parameters there are.
So these such as the learning rate
and regularization coefficient,
I'm going to refer to them
as the optimization hyper-parameters
because these hyper-parameters
directly influence
how the optimization happens.
Of course, there are many
different hyper-parameters
such as the size of the network,
like the width of each of the layers
that's of the network and so on.
But, my sense is that
we just make the network
as large as we can considering
the memory requirement
and the computer requirement.
And then all the matters
is to find the good hyper-parameters
for the optimization procedure.
Now, one really interesting thing.
One really interesting thing
about stochastic gradient descent
in this optimization hyper-parameters
is that they turned out
that the choice of the
optimization hyper-parameters
turned out to influence
the solution that we find
very, very significantly.
What that means
is that even though our
loss function is fixed,
so our loss function is given
depending on what kind of
hyper-parameters we use
for optimization.
We may not be able to
reach some of the solutions
while we end up at some
certain sets of the solutions
that are reachable.
So for instance,
if you start with a
very high learning rate,
at the beginning,
then we might end up with a
well generalizing solutions.
However, if you start with
a very low learning rate,
we can always know what
kind of scheduling we set,
we are very likely to end up
with the non generalizing solutions.
And then this kind of observation
has been made multiple times
over the past few years.
And then some have explained it
from the perspective of so-called
implicit regularization,
and then some others have approached it
from the lens of the importance
of the early stage of learning.
But I don't really care.
I don't really care what
the underlying causes are.
But the important thing to notice here
is that the optimization hyper-parameters,
such as the learning rate,
how you set them will change
what kinds of solutions
you're going to find
or what kind of neural net
you're going to end up with at the end.
So what that means is that assuming
that we going to use as
large neural net as possible,
be it transformers, be it compromise,
or be it multi-layer perception,
with all those fully connected layers,
if you use a large network
and then all that remains
is for us to choose a good set
of optimization hyper-parameters
such as learning rate,
regularization coefficients
and whatnot.
And then to do so,
we now enter the third stage
that is model selection.
And in model selection,
which is often solved as
a blackbox optimization.
What we do is we're going to go through
all possible optimization hyper-parameters
and then for each setup,
we are going to train
this neural net entirely,
take the final solution,
and then evaluate this final
solution on a validation set
that is separate from the training set.
It's very important to use
a separate validation set
that is not training set.
And once we evaluate it
each and every optimization
hyper-parameters,
we are going to pick one
that has the lowest validation loss.
And this is often solved
as blackbox optimization,
as I said earlier,
because it's just so expensive
to train the entire model.
So that is the evaluation,
one time evaluation of this loss function,
that is a validation loss
function is very expensive
because every time we evaluate
this validation loss function,
we need to train the
entire neural network.
And then as I said earlier,
we are assuming that we're
going to use as accurate
on that as we can.
So what are some of
the standard approaches
to this model selection or
the black box optimization
that is used to choose
the right optimization hyper-parameters?
The first one you can
imagine is grid search.
We're going to simply look
at all possible optimization
hyper-parameters
make a grid in this space
of the optimization hyper-parameters
and then evaluate every
possible uniformly space point
in this space of the
optimization hyper-parameters.
It's quite standard,
you know that because it's
available in scikit-learn.
Unfortunately it does not scale well
with the number of hyper-parameters
because of the curse of dimensionality.
We learned about curse of dimensionality
in introduction to machine learning,
condemnatory optimization,
all of those places.
And then you have this
where we really, really literally run
into the curse of
dimensionality in practice.
The number of the uniformly spaced points
that we need to evaluate
in order to exactly solve this grid search
grows exponentially with respect
to a number of optimization
hyper-parameters.
So this is not really what we want to use.
And the interesting thing
is that it turned out
one of the simplest possible solutions
to address this issue of
the curse of dimensionality
has been to simply use a random search.
So we're going to select
a random set of
hyper-parameters drawn uniformly
or they look uniformly from
this hyper-parameters space,
and then evaluate all
those randomly drawn points
and choose the one that has
the lowest validation loss.
Now to be strict, there's
absolutely no reason
why this should work
better than grid search
without assuming a certain thing
about the underlying loss function itself.
However, in practice,
it turned out that for
training neural nets
or in selecting the hyper-parameters
for when you are training neural nets,
this one works pretty well.
This is perhaps one of
the most cited papers
in the field of deep learning,
that is Bergstra & Bengio,
2012 that came out of Montreal.
Of course we can do better.
So whenever you talk to people
and then they tell you that,
"Yo, we are solving this
difficult optimization problem
with random search or the grid search."
You can always tell them that,
"Yo, we can solve better."
And then one way in which
we can solve better,
this kind of black box
optimization problem
is so-called sequential
model-based optimization.
So instead of trying to
evaluate all the points
and then just use those
point-wise information
that we get for every evaluation,
in sequential model-based optimization,
we're trying to fit a model
that's going to look very similar
to the underlying loss function
validation loss function,
using as few a number of evaluation
or the points as possible.
Now what is the
requirements for this model?
This model shouldn't just tell us
how each of the points should evaluate to
or that correspond to the
certain validation loss.
But it should also tell
us given any other point
what the uncertainty is.
So we want to know what are the points
in this hyper-parameters space
for which we know the
actual validation loss of.
And also we want to know
how certain our knowledge
about this validation loss is.
And then using this
two information that is
what is the average
validation loss I can expect
from a particular point
and how certain my prediction
of this average validation
loss is at the point.
Now I can balance them in order
to explore this space
of the hyper-parameters
or the optimization
hyper-parameters to be specific
much better, or the much more efficient.
Now, of course I can go into the details
about the whole thing,
but that's going to take up
probably multiple lectures.
So my suggestion is to go look
at the Brochu et al, 2010,
and then that's a pretty
accessible tutorial
that I really enjoyed reading
to learn about the sequential
model-based optimization.
Now in the context of machine
learning or deep learning,
or even more specifically,
optimization and deep learning
Bayesian optimization
with Gaussian Process
has been one of the de facto standard
in such a sequential
model-based optimization
for model selection
or the optimization
hyper-parameter selection.
This was put forward as a
proposal in 2015 by Snoek et al
and it's a very, a beautiful
way to solve this problem.
And so everything that all the
machine learning people love
kind of come in.
There's a Gaussian process,
there's a Bayesian, let's say treatment,
there is the active learning component
and there's an uncertainty quantification,
it's pretty beautiful.
And then it's become pretty
much a defacto standard
in particular last year,
if I remember correctly,
there was a competition in Europe
about the blackbox optimization,
Bayesian optimization
with Gaussian process
was one of the winning entries,
if not the winning entry.
And then you can use it
quite easily nowadays,
you can just use the scikit-optimize
and then together with the scikit-learn
and then it's going to find
all those nice hyper-parameters for you.
Now, that was good.
But what is the one thing
that all these people
who have been teaching
and who are going to teach
at this deep learning
and reinforcement learning
summer school love
is gradient-based optimization.
And then unfortunately what we noticed
was that the training part,
so that the half of the
optimization in deep learning,
we now know how to
solve it very, very well
with the gradient-based tuning
or the gradient-based optimization,
but the other half, the
model selection part,
we have really haven't used
a gradient-based optimization there.
And then it's been always treated
as a blackbox optimization.
Obviously, because we all love it,
people have worked on gradient-based
hyper-parameter tuning
for some time.
And I'm going to go
through some of these now.
But let's see, oh, I see there is a Q&A.
Let's see, there are
a couple of questions.
Let me try to answer
them before I move on,
because this is a perfect time
to answer some of the questions.
So let's see.
I see a question from Louis Angelica.
What's the full reference
for the Brochu 2010 tutorial
on sequential model based optimization?
Oh yes.
So I can't really recall the title,
but if you Google Brochu 2010
sequential model optimization,
you're going to definitely find it.
If not, I'll try to
actually share these slides
after this talk.
But then there, I'm going to
email it to the organizers
some of the papers that
I think are important
or would be interesting to read
for you to easily refer to
it later after the lecture.
The second question is by our Arfan Miahi.
Does Bayesian optimization scale well
with a number of hyper-parameters?
So no blackbox optimization algorithms
without any assumptions of
the underlying function,
will scale it well with a
number of hyper-parameters
because you can always come
up with a loss function
that just cannot be solved well
without knowing the curvature information.
But at least for the case
of the hyper-parameter tuning and whatnot,
at least personally I've
had a good experience
using Bayesian optimization for
tuning many hyper-parameters
like the layer wise
learning rate and whatnot.
Of course, I believe there
will be few other people
at the summer school who
are much more experts
in Bayesian optimization than I am,
so you should ask them about it.
Let me see.
So let's see, one last question
before I move on to the gradient-based
hyper-parameter tuning by
the anonymous attendee.
Could you give an example of
acquisition function in SMBL?
So let's say
so there are a lot of the
acquisition functions,
and then it turns out that the choosing
or designing the
acquisition function itself
is a bit more of an art than science.
But one of the things
that people have used,
or the kind of standard
one that everyone learns
is the upper competence bound,
or the lower competence,
I don't know what's the
right way to say it.
But that is that the, I
want to choose a point
that's going to have a very low loss,
but at the same time has
a high enough uncertainty
so that I hit the balance
between exploitation.
That is find the low validation loss,
but also I try the points
that I'm not entirely sure yet
whether there is a good solution or not.
So this one is like the
whole, let's say lectures,
that can be done.
And then obviously I'm not
the most qualified one to do.
So, if the ask, let's say Sarah
and many others who are at
the summer school, they know.
Oh, and then there is one short question.
I'm going to answer this one
before I move on to the gradient-based
hyper-parameter tuning.
The question is can the mini batch size
be interpreted it as a hyper-parameter?
Yes, indeed, it can be
interpreted as a hyper-parameter,
but just like the network architecture,
or the size of the network.
I do believe that it's often a good idea
to make the neural network
as large as possible,
as much as you can afford
and then use a mini batch size
that again, you can
afford, as much as you can.
Although, my sense is that
the size of the mini batch
shouldn't matter that much.
I know that that's not true in practice,
especially when we train
transformers and whatnot.
I almost feel like there's just a issue
with the network architecture
or the loss function itself
rather than the size of the mini batch.
But this is a very much open question.
Thanks for the question.
And then thanks, Adriana, who
actually answered my question,
the first question on my behalf.
So I'm going to read out the
title of the Brochu et al.
So it was a paper titled,
"A Tutorial on Bayesian Optimization
of Expensive Cost
Functions with Application
to Active User Modeling
and Hierarchical Reinforcement Learning"
and was authored by Brochu,
Cora and de Freitas.
So if you think about this
model selection and learning,
you notice that these stages two and three
can be just merged into a single
bilevel optimization problem.
So there is an outer optimization,
that is the usual model selection,
but what we notice here
is that the one particular
part of this outer optimization
there is the theta ahead of the lambda
is in fact, the solution, a solution
from solving the inner
optimization problem
that is training a neural network.
So I'm going to just refer to it
as bi-level optimization for now.
The reason why, I refer to
it as bi-level optimization
just for now is that it
turned out in practice,
it's actually not a bi-level optimization.
So let's imagine the idea,
how we are solving this
inner optimization problem.
That is to minimize the
average training loss
with respect to the parameters
of the neural network
that is theta.
So we're going to start
initializing this theta
with a theta zero set drawn
from a sum distribution
that we think are supposed to be good
for initializing these neural networks.
There are so many of
them that are being done.
Like you probably have heard
about the globe initialization,
you probably have heard about
the whole initialization,
you probably have heard of how
PI torch initialize things,
TensorFlow initialize things.
And then somehow everyone
has their own way
of initializing these parameters.
Once the initialization is done,
we're going to use
stochastic gradient descent,
or experiments such as Adam in
order to update this progress
little by middle.
So we're going to compute theta
T given theta T minus one,
and this update direction that is computed
using a mini batch at time step, T
and the parameters from
the previous time step,
theta T minus one.
And after sometime, after sometime,
even if the optimization has
not been solved perfectly,
we are going to just stop.
We often stop it based
on various criteria,
including the early stopping
based on the validation loss,
or we're going to just stop
it because we ran out of time
or we are going to stop it
because we notice that the
change in the loss value
is within some tolerance
that we predefined earlier.
So what that means is that
we actually never find
the fixed point of this
optimization problem,
but we just stop it at some
point that is reasonable.
And what we notice here is that with this,
we noticed that this
whole stochastic gradients
are actually differentiable
with respect to lambda,
that is the optimization hyper-parameter
So rather than solving the
inner optimization problem,
we could imagine that we
just have to write out
a very very long and complicated procedure
to extend the validation loss function.
And then this validation loss function
that includes this training procedure
of a finite number of steps
is differentiable not only with respect
to the primary theta yourself,
but also differentiable with respect
to the optimization hyper-parameter
such as learning rate and
regularization coefficient.
And what that means is that we
can now treat the whole thing
as a single optimization problem.
So we just collect the outer
and look into one optimization problem.
As it was noticed by
Yoshua in 2002, not 2020,
there's a typo that I
just never get to fix it.
So you collect these two
optimization procedures,
and then you get just
one optimization problem.
Now, the problem with optimization problem
is that this function, the loss value,
the validation loss we use
is extremely, extremely expensive.
You can imagine why it's expensive,
you train the entire neural network
for a finite number of time,
but that is reasonable.
And then we're trying to
evaluate the final solution.
So it is very expensive,
but still because the
whole procedure of training
is differentiable
with respect to the optimization
hyper-parameter, lambda.
We can always use the back propagation
and then use the
gradient-based optimization
in order to find the optimization
hyper-parameter setup
then to minimize the validation loss.
Unfortunately, it's very expensive,
not only due to the forward pass,
so that is that the training,
but because of back propagation
through this back propagation procedure
or the training procedure
requires computing multiple copies.
In fact, as many copies
of the Hessian matrix
as the number of the updates we have taken
in training this neural network.
Now, obviously we don't need to compute
the Hessian matrix explicitly,
but all we need is a Hessian
matrix times some vector.
That's the only thing that we need.
Unfortunately, that is still expensive
and we have to do that every
time we made one update
to the neutral network.
So super duper expensive, you can imagine.
And that is for one tiny update
to the optimization hyper-parameters.
What that means is that we
need some kind of approximation
and then by doing so,
we need to make some
appropriate trade-off.
So, three different approaches
have been proposed and tested.
One way, is that you just say that,
okay, we don't really care
about training the neural net all the way,
and then see how that neural net does
in terms of validation loss.
We're going to simply say,
all we need to do is look at
the few steps of training,
and then that's enough for us
to figure out what are good
optimization hyper-parameters.
The second approach is relying
on so-called implicit functions theorem
which is conceptually similar
to truncated backdrop-through-backdrop.
That is that we're going to go all the way
until there is a convergence
or until the training is over.
And then we're going to assume that-
Well, at this point, we
are going to simply assume
that the training loss function
looks really, really nice.
And then we are going to look
at only last one step or the few steps
in order to approximate
this training loss function,
and then use that
information to approximate
what the Jacobian of the final solution
with respect to the
optimization hyper-parameters
could have been.
This one actually works well,
it was actually proposed
in 2000 by Yoshua Bengio.
And then this idea was revived in 2016.
And then this idea is used for
various purposes ever since.
And then the final one
is the reversible iterative optimization.
We give up on reducing the computation,
but we can at least reduce the amount
of the memory that is needed.
Because if you think
about the amount of memory
that is required in
order to go all the way
until the end of the training,
and then backdrop all the way back,
it's actually pretty gigantic.
But then if the optimization algorithm
was designed or selected,
so that are every step is reversible
then you don't have to save
all those intermediate steps.
And that allows us to
compute this gradient,
backdrop-by-backdrop gradient
or the gradient of the gradient exactly
without having to suffer
from the memory overhead.
And as you can imagine,
you can mix and match all
these different things.
In fact, this is a table
coming out of the Lorraine et
al 2020, my favorite table,
because it really summarizes
what people have tried.
And then what are the things that-
What kind of computation
complexity we have?
And then what are the
approximation that has been done?
This is really nice table
and then the paper is really nice.
I highly recommend you to read it.
But what you notice in general
is that there is a clear trade-off
between the computational complexity
or even the computational tractability
and the quality of approximation.
So in order to get a good quality,
we often have to spend
a lot on computation,
including memory.
And then if you want
to save on computation,
we often have to sacrifice
the quality of approximation.
And in that case, we wanted to see,
can we actually do better than this?
So this is what current practice is.
And then we want to see if you
can do it a bit differently
than what most of the people have done.
Although it turned out
that the few other people
have done what I'm
going to tell you about,
but we'll get to that soon.
Before that, let's see,
there is one question.
Oh, Charlie Gothier.
Okay, so can you post the
name of the paper in the chat
in order for us to copy paste?
Good point.
I'll try to look it up and
I'll send you all the list
of the papers that were
referred to during my lecture,
after the talk is done.
Sorry about that.
Another question from Arthur Miahi,
are any of these bi-level
optimization techniques
suitable for optimizing
the neural network?
Well, it's an interesting question.
So it's difficult to tell
what it means to optimize
in your architecture.
If you're asking whether we
can use bi-level optimization
which is what we are doing.
We have a separate
hyper-parameter selection
to optimize the neural net architecture?
Yes, that's what we all-
I know people are working on quite heavily
and then that's what essentially
Cokley has been working on
at Google for the past four years,
trying to use various techniques
or trying out all possible
techniques that you can imagine
to find the best network architecture,
or the primitives they
are going to minimize
their validation loss function,
but it's a very difficult problem.
The reason why it's difficult,
this is a extremely high
dimensional computational space
that is a neural net architecture space.
And then there is not a
clear kind of inductive bias
that we can rely on in order to tell
what are the similar architectures
in terms of the actual generalization.
If we knew that, we could
actually bake that in
as a heuristics for
solving this (indistinct)
but when it comes to
neural net architecture,
I don't think we have a good intuition
what those right metrics
are in this space.
Let me see.
Yes, you meant neural
architecture research.
Hopefully I answered that already.
And then final question,
before we go into the
slightly newer thing,
by anonymous atendee,
can you please go back
to which method was the current
practice arrow pointing to?
Oh, I'm sorry about this.
So everything that I've
talked about so far
is the current practice.
That's what everyone has been doing.
That's what everyone
has proposed to do so,
and then that's what a
lot people have tried
and are using every day.
So instead, let's see
if we can actually think
about a different way to solve it.
And then to do so, we're
going to think about,
we want to talk about a different
perspective to think about
what learning is.
So if you look at the inner optimization,
there is training based on the
stochastic gradient descent
what we can think of
is that it creates a computational graph.
So at every time step, T, we
start with a theta T minus one,
that is the previous parameters.
And then given this theta T minus one,
we're going to compute the update delta.
And then this delta takes
this input, theta T minus one,
as well as the mini batch.
A mini batch of examples
of time steps, T, Bt
and this whole function
delta is parameterized
using this optimization
hyper-parameter, lambda.
Once this delta is computed,
we are going to add this delta.
So the update direction
to the theta T minus one
in order to result in theta T.
And then this whole procedure
happens over and over and over.
And then where do we start?
We start from the initial
parameters of theta zero.
Let's put that aside,
let's think about a
recurrent neural network.
Hopefully you're all familiar
with the recurrent neural
network, or maybe not anymore.
I guess everyone is just
using transformer these days.
But recurrent neural
networks are pretty cool.
So let's just look at it very briefly.
A recurrent neural net is
one of the most general form
of neural network because it is in fact,
a sequential processing machine.
So at time step, T, we
start with the Ht minus one,
that is the memory state
of the recurrent neural net
at T minus one, so the previous time step.
And then we have a recurrent
transition function, G
which often is named as LSTM, or GRU.
And then this G is going to take as input
the previous memories state Ht minus one,
and then the current input Xt,
and computes the next times at Ht.
Because G is parameterized
with its own progress data.
So you can imagine G as a function
that takes as input, Ht
minus one Xt and theta,
in order to produce the newly
updated, hidden state Ht.
So, so far so good?
And then why do we call it
recurring neural network?
Because we're going to use
this same block over and over
as we receive more and more input.
So when we receive the Xt plus one,
G is going to produce Ht plus one.
After that, we're going
to receive Xt plus two,
G is going to produce Ht plus two
and then on and on and on.
And then what you'll notice
is that these two look exactly the same.
And in fact, they have to be same
because I just copied and
pasted one of them to the other.
Then you have to just change the symbols
and then connected to
more arrows on top of it.
What that means is that we can always view
a kind of interactive
optimization procedure
or the stochastic gradient descent,
or the gradient based
optimization procedure
as a recurrent neural
network and we solve.
And then weirdly so,
once we start looking
at the whole learning
from this perspective,
we notice that the gradient
based hyper-parameter tuning
that we just talked about,
is equivalent to training
a recurrent neural network
that corresponds to
learning a neural network.
So what that means is
that we have to think
about how to train this
recurrent neural network,
but we're going to take a quick detour
to talk about how interesting,
training a recurrent
neural network can be.
But before that, there are two questions,
then we try to answer those two questions.
So the first question
is from Joao Guillermo,
how do we choose the
hyper-parameter optimization
hyper-parameters?
Ah, yes, yes.
So, yes are going to
talk about that shortly.
So I'll leave it there.
The other question is from Anwarani,
what are some of the references
on the RNM perspective
for hyper-parameter tuning?
My own paper, I guess.
But, this is nothing new, right?
It's just the same thing
viewed from a slightly different angle.
And I talked about it in
my own lecture and so on,
but I don't think anybody
necessarily wrote down
anything too extensive about
this particular perspective.
Not everything needs to be
written down as a paper, so.
But anyway, let's continue.
So when you think about
the gradient-based learning
or training of a recurrent neural network,
we need to think about it from
what the loss function is.
And then for now I'm going to just assume
that every time step, we take
as the input some observation
and then we're going to predict something
at that time step.
And then for that one,
we have a corresponding
ground truth value.
So we can compute the so-called
per step loss function.
and then the loss function
for the entire sequence,
or the entire example is simply the sum
of this per step loss functions.
That's exactly what is shown on the slide.
Then in order to update
the parameter theta
of this recurrent neural network,
we need to compute the
gradient of this total,
let's say, sequence of the loss function
with respect to the
theta that is recurring
on these parameters.
And then we're going to
update the parameters
little by little.
What that means is that
what's most important
is to figure out how to
compute this gradient
of the sequence of the loss function
with respect to the
recurring of the parameters.
Now, it turned out the
recurrent neural net
has a very interesting,
let's say structure
that allows us to compute
this gradient of the
sequence of the loss function
in one of the two ways.
The first way, I'm going to
just call it future facing
is where we're going to
consider the loss function,
the gradient of the sequence
of the loss function
with respect to each and every time
the shared parameter theta was used.
So at time step, S,
we are going to use the
shared parameter theta
by making a copy,
and then use that to
compute the loss function,
to update the hidden state first,
and then use that to
compute the loss function
at time step, T.
But here because the hidden state
is going to be using the next time step,
the influence of this
parameter copy at time step S,
is going to happen all
the way until the end.
So that is what we mean
by the future facing.
Every time we use the theta,
the parameters at time step, S
we need to consider
how this parameter copy
is influencing the per step
loss functions in the future.
That's the reason why we
call it a future facing.
What that means is that
at every time step,
in order for me to compute the gradient
of the sequence of a loss function,
with respect to the parameter,
used at time step, S,
I need to go forward
and then back propagate the
error signal through time
to time step, S.
So future facing view is a usual way
to compute the gradient in practice.
That is we use a back
propagation through time.
However, because using
parameters and time step
and then computing the
per step loss time step
is somewhat dual.
So you can view it from the
bottom up, or from the top down
you can actually have a past facing view
of gradient computation as well.
That is, we are going to look
at one particular loss
function at time step, T
and then see how all the parameter copies
from time step one, up
until that time step,
and then see how they have influenced
this particular loss
function, at time step, T.
And then to compute that, we
need to look into the past.
That's why we call it past facing.
And then this actually
is an interesting view
because this is not the view
that is most obvious for us,
like the modern deep
learners, including myself.
Although this was obvious in
'80s and all the '90s, I heard.
So just to summarize these two views,
when we run a recurrent neural net
and then compute the
per step loss function,
and then sum all of them
in order to get the
sequence of a loss function,
there are two ways to
compute this gradient.
One is past-facing, that is
that we try to accumulate
the influence of all the past parameters
on the current time steps loss function,
and then sum them all to get the gradient.
Or we can go the other way,
that is the future-facing.
At every time we use a parameter,
we're going to look at
what kind of influence
we're going to have on all
the future loss functions
and then back propagate
through time, this error signal
in order to compute the loss function.
And then after that, we sum them all.
An interesting thing about
the past facing view,
which is in fact the same
thing or similar thing as the-
Probably the same thing as the-
Yeah, same thing.
Same thing as the fuller mode
of the outer differentiation.
This past-facing view, in fact
that means online learning
in the case of the
recurrent neural network.
Because at every time step, T,
we can compute the gradient
of the loss function
at time step, T
with respect to all the
applications of the theta.
So we don't need to really look
at what are going to be
received in the future
but we only need to look at
what have been received so far
in order to compute the
gradient of the loss function,
at time step, T,
with respect to the primary applications
of all the time steps,
which we can just sum,
in order to get the gradient
of the loss function
at time step, T, with
respect to the parameter.
Now, obviously we just
store all these copies
and then sum it
that becomes the gradient of
the full sequence loss function
with respect to parameters.
But every term in this summation
never needed to wait
for the future inputs.
And then the only thing that we need
in order to turn this
into an online learning
is to update the parameters
immediately after we
receive one input at a time.
So we don't really wait
for the entire sequence
and then update the parameters.
But assuming that the
sequence is extremely long
and then relatively stationary,
we're going to just make a small update
to the parameters as we go forward.
And then this allow us
to update the parameters,
even before we receive the full sequence.
And if the length of the
sequence is infinite,
then we're going to simply continue
to update the parameters online
so that the network can adapt
to the varying statistics,
the varying underlying statistics.
Obviously it looks pretty
expensive to compute,
and then it looks like
the amount of the memory
that is necessary is not constant
with respect to the time steps.
In online learning, if it's not constant
with respect to the
length of the sequence,
then it's difficult to say
that it's online learning
because in the infinite limit,
we're going to require some
infinite amount of the memory
that requires infinite model
compute time for access.
Of course, we can be a bit relaxing
and say that we were
going to go for the log n
instead of the O1.
But there's still an issue if
the end goal is to infinity.
But it turned out that by
cleverly rearranging the terms
in computing this gradient
of the per step loss function
at times step, T with respect
to the parameters so far,
we can actually maintain
a constant memory storage
to compute this gradient on the fly.
I'm not going to go into the detail,
it's just a simple, not
simple, it's very confusing,
super confusing
rearrangement of the terms,
but eventually all you need to do
is to maintain a
so-called influence matrix
that tells us about what kind of influence
all the previous, let's
say, hidden state values
and the parameters have
on the next hidden state.
If I have to check out all those details,
this so-called real
time recurrent learning
that was proposed by
William & Zipser in 1989,
becomes a procedure of three lines.
So we update the influence matrix,
compute the immediate credit
that is that the gradient
of the loss function at time step, T
with respect to the hidden
state at time step, T.
And using this, we can
now update the parameters
using the gradient that
is carried over online.
And then we do it over and over
every time we receive a new input.
It's not widely used in practice,
that's probably why most of you
haven't actually heard of it,
or at least haven't used it,
even though you knew about it
because it's still quite expensive.
In particular, the issue is
with the memory complexity.
It's often considered this ON cubed
where the N is the number of neurons.
So we're going to just
consider a single layer,
recurrent neural network,
and is fully connected.
So we have the N neurons
and then the number of
the waves is N by N,
so that is N squared.
And as I said, what this
influence matrix is carrying over
is what kind of influence the hidden state
at time step T minus one
and the weight matrix is going to have
on hidden state at time step, T.
Of course you can rearrange some of them,
but still you end up
with the N cubed number
of the entries in this influence matrix.
But obviously, what that also means
is that if the number of parameters
of this recurrent neural net
was constant with respect
to the number of neurons,
then suddenly this
real-time recurrent learning
is a very viable and perhaps
even preferable solution
to train our recurrent neural network,
because we don't have to wait all the way
until the end of the sequence
in order to update the
parameters just once.
As we read the long sequences,
we can just update the
parameters on the fly.
Effectively, the ratio of the
number of updates per sequence
becomes let's say, is
significantly greater.
So perhaps in this particular case,
this is going to be very useful.
So we have learned how to
train our recurrent neural net
in an online manner.
Is there any questions on this
before I talk about online
hyper-parameter tuning,
which is the meat of this lecture,
except that there is a very thin meat,
we're going to just cover it very quickly.
So I only see Joao's question
that was from the
previous, let's say break.
Yeah, this one I'm
going to get to it soon.
The answer is that it's a bit difficult,
but I'll talk about it shortly.
Okay, otherwise, I'm going to it.
Now at this point, it becomes a bit
let's say relatively
straightforward to see already
what I'm going to end up doing.
What we notice is that
we know how to train
a recurrent neural
network in online manner
and we noticed that learning
with the stochastic gradient descent
or any kind of iterative optimization,
is equivalent to running the
recurring neural net once.
So then we're going to combine these two
so that we're going to update
the optimization
hyper-parameters on the fly.
As soon as I said this, there
are a couple of questions.
Let me try to answer that before I go on.
So the anonymous attendee ask a question.
Does this method allow
for a dynamic choice of hyper-parameters,
meaning that they are not concepts route
or the iterative optimization?
Does this mean that we have
a larger hypothesis set?
This is a great point in a sense that
unlike in a blackbox optimization,
where we're going to fix, or decide,
choose one particular
hyper-parameters configuration
and train them all the way to the end,
and then evaluate the validation loss.
We are going to actually
update the hyper-parameters
on the fly.
What that means is that
the may actually change
as the training continues.
All of course is a big question,
whether this is necessary
and whether it actually
is helpful or hurtful,
but we'll get to that in
the experiments a bit later.
Soon, very shortly.
So there is a question from Leah McKinney,
is this the same as eligibility traces?
Yeah, yeah, it is very much related
to the eligibility traces
and it's a reinforcement
learning summer school.
So I'm not going to try to say anything
that is related to
reinforcement learning myself,
because I'm almost like
not even know this,
I haven't even tried.
So I don't really know much
about the reinforcement learning.
But this will be a great question
for you to ask to all those
RL lecturers later this week.
Let me see one last
question before I continue.
From anonymous atendee,
what is the number of
time steps in the RNN?
Do we consider a time step
as an iteration of training?
Yes, indeed.
We're going to get to the reaction,
we got there already on this slide.
Yes, so every time step in S3D,
so one update is
considered to be equivalent
to one step in the
recurrent neural network
in this particular setup.
But again, this is a perspective
that we look into how the learning is done
or how learning should be framed.
Doesn't mean that this
is the only way forward.
All right, so there's
only 10 minutes left,
so I'll have to continue
a bit more quickly.
So what that means is that we can use
this real time recurrent learning
for training our recurrent neural net
for the purpose of optimizing
or tuning the optimization
of hyper-parameters,
as we train our neural network
using stochastic gradient descent
because training a neural net
with the stochastic gradient descent
is equivalent to running
recurrent neural net once forward.
Now it turned out
that we have some
expensive computation here
because we should be able
to compute the Jacobian
of the hidden state of
the recurrent neural net
that is the primary setup
of the neural network.
So the network parameters at time step, T
with respect to the network
parameter at T minus one.
It's a gigantic Hessian.
Again, we don't have to
compute it explicitly,
but we should be able
to compute this Hessian,
the actual product there
or the gradient Hessian
so that the Hessian and
Jacobian product there.
It's still expensive.
But imagine how it was before,
we had to compute this
Hessian vector product
as many times as we applied the S3D update
to the neural network for updating
the hyper parameter once.
But here we just do it once
every time we update the hyper-parameter.
So this is much more doable,
although it's quite expensive
for a very large network.
And it turned out that for
this particular purpose,
a stochastic approximation
or the stochastic finite
difference approximation
to this Hessian vector
product works pretty well.
Check out this blog post
by Domke, Justin Domke
it's a really concise but very extensive
let's say, discussion
on what is the right way
to do this kind of
finite difference method
to compute the Hessian
vector product well.
So yes, it is computation on the feasible.
Why is it that?
Because often the number of
the hyper-parameters we have
is significantly smaller
than the number of parameters
and the network size.
And then we often make sure
that the number of
hyper-parameters is independent
from the size of the network.
What that means is that
it's not really ON cubed
but it's ON with a very small constant,
that is lambda squared,
that is in front of this N.
And then assuming that the
number of hyper-parameters
is small enough it's okay.
And even if we want to use it
with a lot of hyper
parameters, we can always go
for computationally cheaper
unbiased approximations,
such as UORO, Unbiased
Online Recurrent Optimization
by Tallec & Ollivier, 2017.
So relatively straightforward.
Again, if you have checked out all these,
let's say low-level details
or the gory details,
let me put it like that.
Then it's a three line
or three step procedure.
We update the influence matrix,
we compute the immediate credit,
and then we just update
the hyper-parameters
and we do it every time
we receive a new input.
And then what is the new input here?
As I receive a new mini
batch of training examples.
So before I go into the experiment,
there's two major properties.
First one is that fully online.
We really literally update
the network parameters
and optimization
hyper-parameters simultaneously.
We don't like, let's say,
let's take a look at the
few more mini batches
and then go forward and them
backward, we don't do that.
We update these two like simultaneously.
Every time we update
the network parameter,
we can update the
optimization hyper-parameters.
Of course, if you want,
we can always make them
asynchronous, if you want.
But, generally we just update
both of them synchronously.
And then the second property
is that it's almost exact.
With a small enough meta-learning
rate, it is almost exact.
We actually wrote a nice paper about this,
I put it on archives, submitted to ICML.
Well, and then the reviewers
gracefully pointed out
that we weren't the first
to come up with this idea.
Of course, unsurprisingly,
there was a paper
from Luca Franceschi et al, 2017
where they talk about
this particular algorithm
in one section of the paper.
And then I looked at the
paper, thanks to our reviewers
and then noticed that it's
exactly the same idea.
The idea itself is
really not that dramatic
or groundbreaking
it's just how we view the whole problem.
That's what kind of made it really fun.
but it turns out it's the same thing.
Except that they run only one experiment
but because we didn't
know that Luca did it,
we kind of ran a very
extensive set of experiments
to verify that this idea
actually works pretty well
in practice as well.
So let's go into the experimental details.
We have only five minutes,
so I'm going to just finish it off
and then get some questions.
So we ran an extensive set of experiments,
although, on a small,
very small scale data sets
MNIST and CIFAR-10.
And then we use a four-layer,
fully-connected neural net for MNIST
and then we used ResNet-18 for CIFAR-10.
We used Adam optimizer,
although we did run the same
set of experiments with S3D
without much of the difference
between these two optimizers.
So first of all, does it actually work?
If I compare it to the
blackbox optimization,
can this online hyper-parameter tuning
get to the test loss
or the validation loss
that is as good as the
lowest that we can find
using the blackbox
optimization in one sweep?
Not even a sweep, right?
It's just one training run.
So we compared it against a random search,
as well as the Bayesian
optimization with a scikit-opt.
And then we ran it until
the target test loss
went below 0.3.
And then it turned out
that what be proposed,
okay, so we shouldn't really,
I shouldn't really say propose any more.
But anyway, this online
hyper-parameter optimization
based on R3RL
we're able to find or hit this target
in just one training run.
While for blackbox
optimization algorithms,
obviously couldn't do it in one run.
I mean, it just doesn't make any sense
unless you get super lucky,
and it require many,
many if not tens of runs.
So this actually told us
that it actually works.
And then stability-wise, this is connected
to how to choose
a hyper-parameter
optimization hyper-parameters.
And then,
one of the hyper-parameter
optimization hyper-parameters
is the initialization.
So how do we initialize the
optimization hyper-parameters?
And then do we have to
be very careful about it?
As soon as we have to be careful about it,
or use the utility of this approach
kind of vanishes largely.
So, what we did was we randomly vary
the initial learning rate,
and we randomly vary the
regularization coefficient.
We randomly vary scheduling coefficients
for the algorithm and whatnot,
and also the initialization
of this learning rate
and regularization coefficients.
And then what we have noticed
is that in almost all cases
within one run, it was able
to get to a very low test loss
with a very small variance,
which was very interesting and assuring.
And what was most as
exciting, at least to me,
was that as we increased the
number of hyper-parameters.
So what we did was that we started
by using one initial learning rate,
or the one learning rate
for the entire network.
We started to divide
our network layer-wise
and then you introduce more
and more learning rate.
And then what we saw was that, of course,
the wall clock time increase
as the theory predicts,
but at the same time,
the resulting test loss
decreased almost monotonically.
Which is a extremely good indication
that this is in fact solving
this optimization problem correctly.
Because more theory of freedom,
better solution refines
this has to be rather indirect
but still a very convincing
evidence that this optimization
actually is solving optimization problems.
And obviously one of the
things that online learning
should be able to do so is the adaptation.
So as the underlying let's say, problem
is perturbed or goes through a change
or goes through a distributional shift,
will it be able to
recover or adapt rapidly?
We don't really have a
good, let's say benchmark
to do about test this setup.
So what we did
was to artificially perturb
the hyper-parameters
in the middle of training,
and then we saw if this online
hyper-parameter optimization
can recover from such perturbation.
Turned out, that it can
really do so pretty well
and pretty rapidly.
So, because I really have only one minute,
so I'm going to actually pass this.
Now, one thing that I want
to really emphasize here
is that there is a big question
and then it connects to the
discussion very early on
is that does choice of
the hyper-parameters
really matter in the long run?
If I start with a very large
learning rate in the beginning,
how much does that actually influence
the final solution I find?
If I start with a very high,
let's say regularization
coefficients at the beginning,
how does it actually
influence the future solution
that I will get after training
for let's say hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of updates.
And then if there is such thing,
and then that can only be captured
if the optimization algorithm
is able to capture it.
And then the real-time recurrent learning
does not use the
information from the future.
So can it actually carry
over all those information
to be used in the future
without knowing the future?
It turned out that the answer is yes.
If you reset this influence
matrix over and over,
then the resulting test
loss is always higher.
And then the best case
loss could only be obtained
only when we never reset
the influence matrix,
but carry over all the
information that is out there.
So it was a very interesting and exciting
with the observation we made.
So I'm going to skip through it
because there are a few questions
that I want to answer as well.
So one of the reasons why I decided
to talk about this at this summer school
is that it's not only
about trying to use a setup
that has been proposed or has
been used by the community,
but trying to see the same problem
from a very different perspective,
and then trying to come
up with a new framework
and then based on the new perspective,
often you can actually come
up with a new algorithm
that is not necessarily too complicated
or too groundbreaking, but just a clever,
well, it's weird to call
my algorithm clever,
but let's say the interesting
and fun, let's say way
to reuse many of the ideas
and acquire them from the same field
as well as the adjacent field.
So it was really fun.
We were able to make connection
between the recurrent neural net,
stochastic gradient descent
and the online learning in this work
to get to this online
hyper-parameter optimization.
There are a few things
that needs to be considered
with studying the future.
One is that this one probably
should overfit to a validation loss,
but we cannot actually see the overfits
to the validation loss.
Apparently, I think there is
a weird, let's say interaction
between minimizing the validation loss
and minimizing on the training loss.
We have to work on that one.
The second thing is
that the online learning
is only as good as you're
going to be working
with non-stationary environments.
And then we'll see how it works
in the actual non-stationary environments,
where the data sets shifts,
the distribution shifts
with the infinite stream of the data.
And then final thing is that
we use a lot of different,
let's say hyper-parameters,
and then your idea was working okay,
but still as a hyper-parameter,
such as a meta-learning rate grows,
the inexact nature of the
outcome grows as well.
So what does that actually imply?
The kind of thing-
We need to think about it.
Finally, final slide.
So last week at ICML, one
of the outstanding papers
was given to Vicol,
Metz and Sohl-Dickstein
titled, "Unbiased Gradient Estimation
in Unrolled Computation Graphs
with Persistent Evolution Strategies".
This is really interesting paper to read.
I still need to read it more
carefully and then digest it,
but they actually approach this problem
of their online optimization
hyper-parameter,
and then mix it together with
the evolutionary algorithm
or more of the gradient
free optimization algorithm.
And then they show that
you can actually come up
with the unbiased approach to this.
Still, I always had this thing about,
oh, well if I tend to the
gradient free optimization,
why don't I just use a
gradient and make it better?
But it looks like a very cool paper.
And then if you're interested
in this online
hyper-parameter optimization,
I highly recommend you to
check this out as well.
Well, that actually concludes my talk,
but let me try to answer a few questions
that are in the QA panel.
Joao, hopefully I have
answered your question
so very, very stable
within a reasonable range.
But we probably need to get a better sense
of what the reasonable range is,
both theoretically and empirically.
Next question from Bradley Brigham,
does one run of OHO take
significantly more steps
than a single run in-
No, actually the answer is no.
It turned out that it
doesn't take more steps
or there are sometimes
more, sometimes fewer,
but not that significant difference
from just training one run
with a fixed hyper-parameter set.
Thanks CIFAR for
organizing the whole thing.
(soft music)